morning Los Angeles hope you got your
flu shot reports in five states that a
strange virus is going around so if
you're not feeling well go home take
care of yourself whoa
don't worry you guys I'm sure all those
Californians got vaccinated
oh they didn't oh they're screwed I'm
gonna use fair weather and this is
hashtag news
[Music]
a 10-second teaser for The Walking
Dead's upcoming Los Angeles spin-off
fear The Walking Dead which will arrive
this summer with six episodes Rob during
last night's season finale now you may
not be able to tell much about a show
from 10 seconds but I got this generic
shots of Hollywood scientists walking
down stairs hipsters in Silverlake
a drunk hipster walking downtown that's
a zombie oh look he was probably dead
before it was cool and on top of it all
a reassuring radio DJ telling us about a
weird flu that's affected five states
hope you got your flu shot why are you
so calm DJ we're all about to turn into
walkers haven't you seen The Walking
Dead also how many times do I have to
request the insane clown posse before
you make this jell-o's dreams come true
oh yeah on the weekends
big time despite taking place in Holly
butt home of like every famous person
you've ever known the show is starring
near unknowns that ethnically ambiguous
FBI guy from live free or die hard the
lady cop from gone girl and a young
Baltimore but if we're lucky the show
will pull a dawn of the dead and show us
some celebrity zombies telling telling
we get Burt Reynolds
[Applause]
oh no that's actually just a clip from
Modern Family considering Holly has four
times the population density is Atlanta
here The Walking Dead will get even
bloodier than the original but hey at
least our walkers will still be hot that
Botox don't run baby you know what I
just realized we're taping this in Los
Angeles right now oh my god Skywalkers
we're the crew oh my god why do you guys
look like zombies because we're really
ugly oh we're right right
for God's I roll up they are that's it
for ashtag news you guys please like
this video and if you haven't yet
already subscribe so that you can see
more of our videos let us know in the
comment box which celebrities you would
like to see zombified I mean honestly
it's kind of hard to tell in this
industry I mean some of them already
look like zombies I'm Heath Fairweather
and I just spotted a zombie Chris
Hemsworth oh look at that amount of
bullets come to mama
[Music]